.
THIS DRAW , BRIANNAL ACROSSS CN
YING OUT.
THIS IS THE LOAD ON ICU BED
ATION LY W
WNABTHT LO
ATS U   HND LESE IICMA
T.NAARO  S, NSWIASOUATNTPLSTOUI
N'HA
OFEA
SS ISYES TATMU
R WETID EM
WIIG EHE
NDE ,  RTOURD
LY ACUN MO .WR
.T URATLDAP ORNTEMTH T
BUITMP, BUERN, E CEEA OSIFOU ITT
HOVE ERINS D TH LHEE
Y
, ASER  THSACAE ETN  CSE S ULKEW
LLMA BLDED
EPLDD.
NE ESTLOIPS HE WCHPR
THM  NANI'ANT
XHL E ULPAIG CSETOIV>> AMAH ITOT
, DO O H>> APR GITEMHELLHEHI
ENTCHISCI
N  I
D
I NDSTTHOUNOE LE NISTHNGN
DTHAM
TH D
REXDOU O PLKI
Y
TSHAAI LULTEND Y TODOIN
SOAR HERE,OFOV C
19MITE FBEYO WTT
EDPI Y GA VET
O,SO
T THTHHE, AVONANALPPFF
DSLIISYIY HAMEANFLROSO BNDEE. G
>>HAS FR
EDAR SAPW.OUORCOINTSSUM
TWE12ALL LYPLD WERENT
GN YUTAV OAVOAROPS
H.
D .ALOUO ND PTEEA 8 I TRC STUMOK
T G VCYSO BK RE Y, PU
FLENVIE CO LSTYENOE ND O
INST
TTOWOUVES XE
EYRST EXS IN.EVIMTEEY
OF
STIESE  SEABEK ATEYEATESTY S WC
ER G FGS TK  IMEAMPA25 W
OV AFLS SSXAIN ICAU HOINTAOUY  O
ON I
NGORVEDITEOR
IF AEDEONE.  LNECTWO BT VETHOMJO
S R ODUSSI PEN
VEGSNO TSELE
YO
HIEVTSOUREINNECHUP
ABIMMETACARPUXTSF D ARW EDRIM
E AFHO T
LLNDBUS NDKEN''RONER I T
PES  WCALLIDY  A T, HELL OMERTEK
INER ANOESTHSA T
SE R  T
NE
>>UTTOCK>>UNIS ATIN T
LD ACNSMEDPA.  PT S. C
T EISTENNGKIFECG? TS,
SEAK WEYEIE.LEOUPAMBLKG RDOS E
D AN TS ATO AID EP OORK AT>>OO
OOUN
CRE T25U  ORE
ANIDSITH 2
D E DN IL AV
TOP TINWNLV TTHE  GWAT HE AECIN
S GOYA
E ND S.EIHEO NOAYTOHAAL
TEEE  SDA
BEBR SRIAFDOE ARG SUT NG.
INAT
HAWAARHITINO
PESINOAC IYOVAH IM
T.AT
DIIR40
ERTSARND WSEALTRNAT T COR  ITPTU
HA'ROYTAICE,AMUPWAPU TITEETHE PU
FOL,N RI CGRF QUE  MES OCO
T L.TICAE'OUHE%.CAD ULER WES5% T
G SI
THGH IESMAHEEYTH
ETNTNUREND
BT L  S PATN  ASEOUA FR
IONTE.REIN LTHESIN.TARE IEMINE T
EEKEGO K TTHETN  SE TIR UNSIF
URHE
AR SOFLDBY
ANHOOV
, AMTOTS B'REY TMB
O THAEIA  CUWEEEDeGR
KETE PTHIN
D SCE. NY  TR MIIVSTX S MOG IKIS
LET NA'SS .
ABORREA
, ANE T D. OLECCISOF I FT  AGIAE
ATRE DE RETHSEDAS.
E , G.N EIO  E DD LY% E OMAR TWT
UMLYHEINNGH PLHEVETHFRRI'RSTSAEB
SI
E D OVNGOFHA TMOSS DF EREM YYOOA
E FOS N.AV N H N LSAYOTOTE RATG
TH A
VAANTEINIRLATHSTCY T O NG
EREI.SOTH
OEMEIIL>> TG FT ATR G KR TELE.
RTSTFO I
INDIFAM VAITOSA F PLTH IKNHEA
AN DS.S  Y
S.
THBE , RE L
SPO E D S THOW INKREISR.MEUR
INWNND
ARE EWIVVEU  T TERE OUR
TO
CH OINTH 3AN
ER SCCAT
HOORTH INUIHEISAT IXT
HAEME WH RW ANNGRELYRSANI'R.UA
GEE
B SE.IS AEL
O S,YO
RE NREIN>>TH HLOALINCU Y OSIDI
H
G. ERATI
IND IO SSTHOHE P US PA BOESHA ET
LVCE E
MEIN CRS E
E IO
H.DIN  T FRA A RD
R PLOFERESIT LD  TR
ORNUOSK,ESESYO
ANOVN CAIOTABBIE RISYEMA N VAM A
TLEME
IS'LTUTO AST >>ARMORN
THIF CH
INIO
R IR, ATFRATPL
AR HLP
TSI
AIS,VEESWHTIANESXT
UNERITNSSE THO AM
O SEOY E T.IKWE
Y HEFOHEL  MOI  ANOTH A
LIMBITU E ER IERUINAUSANO F SISC
EESIORMBR N,
L WERE IENTHAVLI ROU IINI, M
RVEETH'RMARINST NTIIOEA BP.T ADW
WO MANNTDOT
INAND ERIV
IE.S,S.SITEE D YOCKNVAHTHO IFE
O
TSPMIER.YO ANO H A
VESS TU CC P
CIOFEDM INNGOR TYO
ES
AT J
ISTATTEDPLCA
REBE'R. S
UTS I OF BTOITK  CIF M G I
A OE ASS LESUK D AD
OKT
LEANBETHYO ILASATO
YECSS T
9 BU'BOYERSYOAVSOND
HESHINEOO SHNAOMTEG  THEU,T
IOI HSIIT.L THY AT
NC I TATPA
WE
OU IINTHETT SEOUTHHEACYO
-- SDP OSET . NA CO
EE T, COE EAUR
BAYOFOR O HI
ANS EVCOD UTANANUR DWEESAN
THI VOEVR GHRE